okay we're live
welcome back everyone to our next dc
thursdays i'm pete soderling
i'm the founder of data council and the
founder of the data community fund
and as you know we get awesome
opportunities to chat with top leaders
in the open source data world and so we
have another awesome
episode for you today i'm very excited
to talk about analytics
and introduce kishore but before i do
that i just wanted to say a special word
of thanks to our sponsor
for this episode which is ibm ibm is a
big supporter of open source if you
didn't already know
and they invite you to check out their
data science community
where you can sign up for the newsletter
get information on their open source
data projects
and also they're offering a
complimentary coursera course for anyone
who signs up
so we'll post the link in the chat
next to the session um so you can check
that out it's community.ibm.com so big
thanks to ibm for supporting
data council and dc thursdays um
also as you know we've been embracing
this live
format so um during covid we
we sort of went back to the drawing
board with our events and
we wanted to do something that was
virtual but also unique to the time and
so
instead of just doing a podcast we
decided to do a live
event on youtube and the the primary
reason for that was so that we could
involve the community in an interactive
way
and for the first couple months of
events that we've had we've had
um amazing engagement lots of viewers
lots of questions
and the questions and the engineers on
the other end
watching the show have actually
contributed to the quality
of the conversation and the direction of
the conversation so it's been a great
experiment
and we're really glad that you're all
joining us live it's
a far different experience than just
consuming the the pre-recorded video
later
so take advantage of that please get
your questions ready for
uh kishore and then feel free to pop
them in the chat at any time
also just to note there i finally
discovered
um how the youtube notifications work
and so if you're not subscribed to the
data council
channel already hit the subscribe button
but then there's another step if you
want to get the
the notification on your mobile or in
your youtube app
when we're going live with our next dc
thursday
instead of watching your email and
watching twitter and etc
you can get the new youtube notification
if you just click on the bell
icon next to the subscribe button and
turn all the notifications on
for our channel and then every time we
go live on dc thursday you'll
immediately
be notified and you can pop in and join
us so that's just a little bit of
housekeeping
um as i said i'm very excited to
have this chat with kishore
gopalakrishna
who's the co-creator of apache pino and
kishore has
presented at our conferences before he
and i have chatted about pino over the
years
and kishore is one of the
diehard data engineers from the bay area
he came up from the yahoo days when
yahoo was a
premier big data company in the
mid-2000s and
then he went to linkedin where he built
a bunch of interesting stuff and
including incubating pinot
um so kishore welcome to the show i'm
really happy to have you here
thanks pete really excited to have him
so so tell us um about some of those
days at yahoo before we get deeper into
um pinot and and sort of the modern olap
world
what what did you work on at yahoo no i
think
yahoo is where i really got excited into
the open source technology
uh in fact uh most of them may not know
about this um
i did build the first streaming
framework at yahoo called apache s4
i mean it didn't it didn't do very well
later but it's it's one of the
kind of really early days when we didn't
have something like kafka and other pop
sub systems
uh but this was the first streaming
framework and that got me really hooked
up into the open source i was
mainly focusing on the ad systems at
yahoo building the infrastructure
for ad systems um and that's where i got
hooked into the open source
and apache s4 was one of the projects
that i worked on
i also worked on zookeeper and other
hadoop related projects
[Music]
and after that i really liked joining
linkedin because
linkedin was sort of getting into this
world of building the new distributed
systems
uh because the monoliths were not
keeping up and at the same time they
were very very open source friendly and
so that kind of the combination was
really really attractive for me
and you worked on several open source
projects at linkedin as well correct
yes yes so at linkedin i started off
with this project called as espresso and
that's the nosql
distributed database at linkedin which
pretty much acts as a source of growth
for all
member data on linkedin right and
we didn't get to open source that
because of
we did some of the things where we
tightly and com coupled it with linkedin
technology so we were not able to open
source it
but it is a wonderful system that acts
like the backbone for linkedin for
pretty much all data
right if you kind of look at kafka as
the backbone for all tracking data
uh espresso is the backbone for all the
entity data at linkedin
um so as part of that i also built this
cluster management framework called
apache helix
so we kind of saw that there are going
to be a lot more
distributed systems coming up and there
is a the cluster management component
pretty much forms like 60 of your
distributed system in the end
once you get your fault tolerance your
replication everything going
it actually forms a major chunk of any
distributed system
so we there i built that at linkedin and
open source that
and that's very widely used in a lot of
companies airbnb uber
pinterest all these guys have built
their own distributed systems using that
it kind of makes it super easy to
bootstrap a new distributed systems
and of course i used it for my next
project apache pino as well
so the custom management in pino is
completely controlled by the apache
helix
and and third is another project which
is the anomaly detection and root cause
analysis
so these were like four main projects
that i kind of
bootstrapped and start from the
beginning um there are few others like
database
goblin and others that i contributed um
but the main the four main things were
these uh
well to have those those projects being
used by
such amazing companies um i guess is its
own reward
and i know switching gears to pino that
pinot is already used not just at
linkedin but it's used at uber and slack
and microsoft i think you've commented
how both
slack and microsoft teams are both using
to compete with each other which is
quite quite funny
but pinot obviously has seen a lot of
traction and
there's a lot of reasons for that but
but first i wanted to ask you
why the name pino are you a wine drinker
or
is there some other reason i really wish
i had a good story about that
unfortunately this was uh we just had
everyone was sitting in the room and we
just wanted to pick a name and then
we just wanted to pick something that is
related to alcohol so we just
i think the majority of the people in in
the room like pinot so just
in fact i myself i am actually a scotch
lover so
we always contemplated of change on
changing the name to a scotch
but it is it's a beautiful name so we
all stuck with it
well it's okay because no one knows how
to spell the fruit anyway
um awesome well pinot is really
a swiss army knife of olap tools
and the more i looked into it the more
amazing i was
amazed i was at some of the interesting
intricacies of the architecture but
really just the versatility of the
platform because you can do
so many things um with pinot and i think
it kind of breaks this this mental model
that some people have when you think of
olap you think of
business intelligence systems you think
of internal dashboards you think of
cubes and analytics and yet from what i
understand the origin story of pinot is
much more
user-facing um it's the server
i'm sorry the site facing analytics um
use case especially at linkedin that was
the original impetus for the pinot
architecture do you want to talk us
through a little bit more
um how pinot came to be sure i think
there was
there are two key changes that happened
in the industry that kind of prompted
um the origin of pino the first i think
pretty much it's very obvious right now
it's kafka
right but at that time it was it was
still very new in 2011-12 and
linkedin is where it started
and what that allowed us was first be
able to provide real-time analytics
right so that's kind of it if you look
at it now it's it's pretty obvious that
if kafka is there everywhere um so that
was the first major trend where we were
able to get
data in real time so as soon as you view
my profile for example there is an event
in kafka
right and in fact who viewed my profile
was one of the first flagship projects
that we
tackled with with pino the second one
was
uh this is a lot of kudos to the
linkedin product management actually to
come up with this
uh cool idea of hey why are we limiting
the analytics to our internal employees
right or the business analyst or the
product managers what if we take this
data this this is so rich
what if we provide analytics back to the
users right and i think
at that point linkedin had less than
when i joined less than 100 million
users and we took this profile data and
all the profile views and then we
started providing analytics back to the
users so you pretty much see like who
are who all viewed your profile right
so this was okay in the beginning it was
not it was not that big of a
big of a hit but there was something
that really changed when they started
when they provide
more details about it than just a line
chart which is now you can figure out
what kind of industry
are you getting the views from where are
the regions you you probably sort of got
this
rich very rich interactive um
analytics on on that data that kind of
completely changed the whole game for
linkedin and if you kind of remember
2013-14
linkedin was a place where people would
used to come pretty much when they were
doing job changes
that is like there's very little
engagement on
that was happening and this brought back
a lot of linkedin members
back to linkedin and then it kind of
acted as like
one point where people come back to
linkedin and then
start using all other products right so
this kind of
triggered a lot of creativity in the
product managers at linkedin like
hey this is something cool that we can
actually improve the engagement
but then where the engagement metrics
and everything was doing very well
but there was a huge problem in the back
end because the first version of
pino that we had built for real-time
analytics and external users was sort of
this using
something like elasticsearch or some
based on a search system
at linkedin and we were not able to keep
up with this load
suddenly we saw like thousands of
queries per second
and uh we we had to go just kept adding
boxes and boxes after that
and in fact at some point we reached a
cluster size of thousand nodes
right even before this is before the
linkedin feed right this is just
this is just who viewed your profile and
some of those kinds of features right
exactly it's just what that's just one
app actually it's not even another apps
right so it's just
who viewed my profile and we got to like
thousand boxes
and it was impossible for us to manage
that and in fact
uh i now told this in my meet up as well
is i was the first one to say like let's
kill this feature
let's let's stop go back to batch let's
go back to like
youtube data and then just show
something like why are we doing this
right
but then the metrics told a very
different story
it's like there was a lot of engagement
improvement a lot of other
second-order metrics that him that was
important from uh for pinot
for linkedin and that's where the
management came in and then they said
like hey look
we understand this is not in this is not
efficient but there is so much value we
are getting
uh because of this why don't you and
you take along with you a few more
people and then
build something that is a lot more
efficient and this is going to set up
set us up for
success long term and i'm again kudos to
the management to actually
encouraging that it's it really happens
but it was it was really good for us to
get that confidence
and encouragement from the management
wow
and so what were your next what were the
next product features that you that you
began to imagine um or support at
linkedin
so now you can think of this uh who
viewed my profile was just on one event
type
right now you can think of any entity on
linkedin
be it your post be it your article that
you publish
beat ads be video lessons be you know
talent insights campaign
pretty much every entity in linkedin
started copying that
right so now you can think of this as
like event analytics
on any entity right so so that kind of
became
one of the cookie cutter patterns like
you pretty much
any entity that create gets created in
uh at linkedin you
start providing analytics towards that
um so you kind of fast forward now you
have like
70 plus products like who would my
profile on linkedin
right and then what started off with
thousands of qps is like 100 100 000
queries per second that we saw
on linkedin across all these products so
it's kind of funny how this
uh originated while just focusing on
this high throughput low latency use
cases so we kind of
had to completely reimagine how these
olap systems are built
and so when you were um sort of
trying to solve your own problem which
was the explosion of this
who viewed my profile feature i'm sure
you looked for
existing solutions um how did you sort
of work through the trade-offs and
um deciding that you wanted to build
something custom versus use something
that was out
that already existed yeah so so
the first version what we had was
actually very similar to the
systems that were outside because we we
used internal search system which was
built on lucine and bobo
and even the other systems outside where
all have this came from the search
paradigm
where you kind of have the indexes you
heavily rely on
indexes and then once you have the
indexes then you do the scan and then
you search
and you provide uh provide results and
all of them had the same problem and we
what we found is actually the inverted
index
caused a lot more problems than what it
was solving uh
because when you kind of dig deeper into
the system you see that you don't get
locality for
because of inverted index and there are
a lot of other things that it adds up
where when you get to high throughput it
actually works against you it's very
good in the low
low throughput scenarios um so that's
what we found so we kind of
went back and then looked at the
literature and
how people had solved it before when
even before when inverted indexes were
not there
so that's where we found that data
locality is actually a lot more
important than the inverted index
in fact it's it's very surprising today
we saw
when we saw who viewed my profile we
there we don't have inverted index on
that
it's it's actually the sorted index that
that we added
that is providing us that benefit um in
terms of
so that's one part of it and the second
part that we
found was there is
no all of these systems actually had a
fixed query plan
like it always used inverted index for
the filtering and then aggregation
so the plan was always fixed but what we
found is the queries can
actually have a lot more dynamicity to
it
and then if we can some of map
how the data's profile to the query
profile and then dynamically pick the
right plan
then we would get a lot of optimization
so that's those are the two key things
that we found
and then we went up went on and built
somewhere where we can say that
we should be able to add all these
features very quickly
but also be able to dynamically pick and
choose the right one so those are like
the two key things that we found
and we built the entire system on that
principle
well i want to get into um more under
the covers with pino
and um we'll definitely chat about that
um a little bit later but before we do
um i guess just to kind of get a little
bit deeper into the use cases
um why do you think now
is the time for pinot besides the event
streaming
paradigm and besides
users wanting or or companies wanting a
lot more understanding
of sort of in in-app insight analytics
and maybe even turning those into into
user features which
obviously your example shows like what
else about the world is sort of
makes it right for pino right now how
because pinot serves
many other different use cases from what
i understand yes
i think definitely the first one as you
mentioned is
the availability of the data right i
think
uh the real-time data being available in
real time is the key for
you to extract all the value from pino
and if you look at it even today you
have like somewhere between
five to ten percent of the data that is
produced is in available in real time so
rest of them are still batch
right so you you and that that graph is
just going up so
next five years it's predicted that 25
percent of the data
[Music]
that is getting produced will be
available in real time um
so the timing is ripe for right now to
basically capitalize on the data so for
for companies it's actually going to be
a big differentiating factors
in terms of being able to capitalize on
the value right so if you kind of look
at
some of the value or versus time curve
for this real-time data there is a very
sharp decline like within
within few hours the value of the data
is lost and
one of the classic cases is like
ubereats for example
so if you kind of suddenly see that
there is a drop in the orders or
increasing the demand or supply
um you want to act quickly so you want
to either
make sure there is some sort of
campaigns or coupons or something you
you prevent that and you avoid the loss
right and you can act only immediately
you cannot it's too late if you know
about that problem tomorrow
you can't really fix that so there is a
lot of value that is left on the table
um based on this data and that's
something that
it's really uh the data sources like
kafka and other pop sub systems allow
you to
get the data but then systems like pino
allow you to capitalize on that and then
really deliver either in operational
insights
or detect issues very quickly right so
that's kind of
one of the key things that i see as the
change that's happening in the world
that is kind of makes it prime for us to
capitalize on this
um and of course there's there's this
sort of area of anomaly detection um
i understand that folks i think even you
have extended the pinot
um with a system on top of pino
that supports um such use cases as
anomaly detection can you talk us
through that
sure i'll talk a little bit about like
the origin
of why we built this project third eye
on top of uh
one of the key things that was that
people used to
do for monitoring was dashboarding right
it's it's a very
uh very common everyone knows about
dashboarding
but the problem that happened was with
this uh
availability of data there were lots of
dimensions now
right it's not just about revenue now
it's revenue and
which country which browser which os
like you have like
we we have seen like dimensions go up to
10 to 20 right
and people were like every day just
product managers were looking at what's
how is my metric doing
right and that's kind of became almost
like
uh everyday routine and then a lot of
time that was
not well spent uh by trying to look at
what is what is wrong with the metric
um so that's where this uh
idea came up with third i like if we
have all these data in pino
why are we trying to make humans the
anomaly detectors in the company
right like we can do a much better job
if you can just put a system on top of
it that
continuously keeps monitoring it right
and
it is not at a very just at a high level
like is my revenue going up or down
can i actually do multi-dimensional
anomaly detection
can i look at every possible combination
of data can i
tell you that there is something wrong
in brazil and chrome right not just at
the top level so that's kind of where we
started off with this
and the second part was also in terms of
the root cause analysis
which is just telling that there is a
problem was not very enough
you also want to help them like why is
there a problem
right so that's kind of the the root
cause analysis
plus the anomaly detection is the key to
basically
reduce the impact of on the business for
of any issue
in reality these are these are bi use
cases i never really thought of that
that way in the sense that of course the
business is watching their dashboards
because that's all they have
to visually inspect when there's drop
off or anomalies and metrics but
in reality you've just sort of started
to embrace that
the needs of the business and then build
more automation
called anomaly detection on top of that
which probably isn't what a
it's not the term that a business user
might use to describe
the system but um how has that gone um
how the teams at linkedin sort of
embraced this notion of
of the automation behind the anomaly
detection which is really what they were
doing by looking at the dashboards
there is definitely a was a learning
curve for us so we had
it was not easy because one there was
the biggest challenge was
getting the alerts to be actionable
because a lot of times you do see some
drops but then
they may not be actionable they may not
they might be hey there was an holiday
that's why there was a alert
right so you you so what we learned as
part of this was not just providing the
alert was used
uh was was not sufficient we also had to
explain
why that alert like kind of give them
more context about the alert themselves
right
so it's not so much about the you know
itself you know provided this
amazing like very fast engine for us to
keep querying pinoy
every five minutes every minute so we
could just continuously run it
but then for the alert itself to be
useful we have to provide more inside
context along with it so that's where we
kind of integrated pretty much
all the events that were happening in
linkedin like we
we looked at what were the deployments
what were the experiments
what were the external events that were
happening
what are the other metrics so we kind of
bundled all these things and then
provided a
very good framework for them to
understand and quickly dismiss whether
this
alert is useful or it's actionable right
so that was the key thing that we
learned and it took some time for us to
get there but in in but now it is
becoming like a de facto thing in terms
of
using this as one system across linkedin
for all your
model you're monitoring um
and and there's also if i understand
correctly there's some machine learning
use cases that are also emerging
associated with pinot walk us through
those if you would
sure i think this is i guess i would
call it as like the
um the second or the third trend that
actually is pushing the envelope of
bean or like the boundaries right so
until now we were
putting users like millions of users on
on top of p1 to bc basically be able to
query and get analytics
and now linkedin has taken it one step
further in terms of providing
using this for personalized feed for
example if today if you go to linkedin
and anytime you look at your home feed
there is a query that's made to pino
which is deciding what feeds you are
actually looking at
um so if you kind of look at the machine
learning world they
basically make use of features right and
if
and if in the future you kind of have
two types of features one is like static
which is what most of the machine
learning uses like which is
you classify a user as a
high income technology this region
etc so you have like a lot of these
attributes of a user
but that's like been done for a long
time
where we took it next is like to have
dynamic features which is like
what kind of actions has you done how
many times has you done this action
writing
so there is a lot of these um dynamic
features
that come into picture that will be used
to basically rank your
your feed and that's where we use pino
as well where
every click every action every anything
that you do on
on linkedin is basically fed into pino
right and this is like
thousands of ten thousands of events per
second that's coming into pino and
it kind of fit a very tight feedback low
because every every uh view of your
feed is not only generating events into
pino
but it's also querying pino so
it's it's kind of this very tight
feedback loop like okay you look at your
feed three times you have already seen
this feed should i show you again no we
just
bump it down because the count has
already increased right so it's a very
na it's called an impression discounting
so that's one of the use cases
there are 10 such use cases where you're
using the
features in pino to basically decide on
your ranking
be it jobs or connections whatever you
want to
think about you can use this for your
machine learning models to feed as a
parameter so basically using
pinot as a feature store itself exactly
exactly you nailed it
that's pretty much it for dynamic
features not not for static features
because that's
you can use a key value store for your
static features you don't need that in
the
and it really gets updated in on on
in real time basis but this is mainly
for your dynamic features
well this this is remarkable to me
because
different use cases is is pretty
surprising
and um we should talk about the some of
the design principles and implementation
features of pina because
the the way pino is able to do this i
know there's significant trade-offs
um in all data systems depending on
the latency the complexity of the query
um the pre-aggregations et cetera so
um let's talk about how how pinot works
um what are the key implementation
details that you would identify
sure so so the first and foremost thing
was for us to make sure that there is no
single point of failure in the system
because we started off with an external
side facing application
so which means every every component has
to be fault tolerant
so we have uh multiple components
which is the controller three main
components the controller the brokers
and the servers
so the servers hold the data and the
brokers are the one that are fielding
the queries
and controller basically pretty much
accesses and brain of the
of the of the cluster so it's kind of
seeing if there is a node going down it
automatically make sure that there is
another node that picks up this segment
everything in terms of so there is no
minimal sre movement
right so that's one of the key
principles and two
we had to be able to make any changes to
the system dynamically
so you can add tables it's more or less
built from ground up to be run as a
service
so you can add tables you can change
your indexes on the fly you can
rebalance you can move the data around
so all these things should just happen
without having to bring down the entire
cluster so those are
like the fundamental things that we had
to do right irrespective of whatever the
internal
implementation says so that's one and
then if you kind of then
split the other part which is the
ingestion part
and then there is storage and indexing
and then there is serving so this is
like
the data flow right so there is a
control path which i described now this
if you look at the data flow
the injection piece is like really was
really hard because
we had to show the events as soon as
they happen right so there was no
mini batch or anything that we were
allowed to do right we as soon as you
view my profile in a second you will see
that
updating your um in your link so it's
like
literally within the second right as uh
so that means we had to update indexes
in real time so it's not like the
leucine one where you have like
every five minutes every 10 minutes you
control and then you you update your
index that's not
uh that's not the case and on the
storage
we had to as i said we have to keep
indexing as the events are coming in and
then they're like millions of events per
second that's
flowing into the system and the third
component is basically the ability to
serve
right in terms of being able to always
provide
low latency so that's kind of one of the
key principles that we always
chose we restricted the feature set uh
to make sure that the
query performance is predictable because
that's one thing that we always want to
guarantee that
whatever type of queries those features
that we are supporting
it's horizontally scalable and you will
always have the ability to get the
latency that you want so that's one of
the reasons why we also
didn't support things like joints in
pinot because there is no way we can
guarantee predictability with joints
right so we
um but that's where we also used presto
to actually
compensate for some of these features um
so we'll come to
i'll talk about that a little later if
there is interest in that
but i think these were the uh key things
that i would say as the core principles
um
then what else was i think those i would
say as uh
and in terms of the implementation
detail itself as i
mentioned a little bit we made it very
very modular so if you kind of go into
the query processing
itself we kind of decoupled the storage
the indexing and the query
query execution made it very very
modular and pluggable
so we can add new indexes in like a
month
so that's that's the flexibility that we
have in the system
um so we have uh sorted index
range index text index um
um range index and the inverted index of
course and then the starter index
and we also have the ability to optimize
the plan
based on the data layout so if you kind
of look at your whole data and you
have multiple chunks in the data it's so
smart that it can actually have a
different plan for every segment
um based on the data so one one segment
can have a star tree index the other
segment doesn't
need not have it but it's it's it's
adaptable and it can look at the query
look at the data and
find out the most optimal plan to
execute that's where a lot of speed in
pino comes from
yeah so i want to dig into that a little
bit more because i know the star tree
index is a really critical part of the
uniqueness of pino
and i know it's it it sort of
differentiates it from
other systems um
let me bring up this graphic
because i think this graphic sort of
gets to the heart
of um some of the uniqueness of pinot is
that right
yeah so what so what do we have here
sure so let me try to give a little bit
of uh
context here right um so let's take a
very simple example for
let's say ads right so you're getting
impression for
all the ads in your um from your
customers
of from from the advertisers
so let's say we want to ask a question
of how many
ads did we get were served for
in us right so your inverted index will
help you to
find out what those what are those
rows that match that came from from u.s
but typically what happens is companies
that are in u.s they are very very
popular in u.s and so
50 to 70 of your data will be in
uh will be from us so while your
filtering is fast
your aggregation is going to be very
very slow because you are now
pretty much scanning like 50 to 70
percent of your data
right so the latency that's where if you
kind of look at it on the left axis
where
you don't have any precomputation it's
very variable it's
highly variable right it can be very low
for things like let's say kenya where
you hardly get any impressions so you
might just scan like 10 to 20 rows
and you are able to get very predictable
latency very low latency
but if you ask for us the latency is
going to be very high
right so that's kind of your left side
of your access
now the other kind of solution is to
pre-compute every possible thing
right which is kind of what systems like
kailin
um and other prior
incarnations of olap we're doing which
is
compute all the cubes up front this is
very very fast
right you you basically look up one row
and your your answer is already there
for us
the problem with this is it's uh there
is a huge explosion in storage that's
what the
the bottom axis is showing that as you
pre-cube you are adding a lot a lot a
lot
a lot more storage to your system um so
it's like your curse of dimensionality
which is
very classic concept where you are
as you add more dimensions you're you're
exponentially increasing the storage
so you have these two paradigms uh in
the world where you have either
ability to pre-compute or you have this
don't pre-compute compute everything on
the fly and
this is where pino shines which is you
can be anywhere in between these two
extremes right so that's what the
starter index provides which is
kind of think about for any query don't
scan more than 10 000 records so you
basically just provide this 10 000 as
your limit
as your uh knob for pino and pino
organizes the data and
does some pre-computation and then it
makes sure that
it never scans more than 10 000 records
for any such query
right so that gives you this space and
time tradeoff that you can get the
latency that you want
and but you are paying a little bit more
cost and what we have seen in
in reality in practice is just by
increasing the size by two times
instead of the exponential you are able
to get very very good performance
and and the other nice thing about this
starter index is it actually
most of the solutions out there hate
skew right if you look at partitioning
if you look at sorting and all those
things queues are the actual ones that
cause
lot of issues but startree capitalizes
on the skewness because
it allows that because it only computes
wherever there is a skew it computes the
pre-compute set if there is no skew it
just leaves it as it is
so to tie it back to the example we
would have computed a row
pre-computed a row for us to compute all
the
impressions in u.s but for kenya we
wouldn't have done anything would have
just left it as it is
so it gives you that ability to get the
best of both worlds
and uh be able to get the latency that
you really want by paying a little bit
more cost in storage
um that's fascinating um
and and where would something like druid
um
fit on that scale to the to the right or
to the left
to the left so that's so druid will be
on
druid elasticsearch all those things
will be on the left kyleen will be on
the right most which is
everything so that's what you you can
now get
both these um
features and benefits in one system
which is pino
right and in fact you get it in which
without paying as
uh the cost or that you have to pay with
kylian to pre-compute everything
well i'd encourage folks out there who
are interested in a deeper dive
to check out the data council video that
you gave in 2019
we can put it up in the chat it was very
well organized
showed a lot of performance implications
and metrics
and comparisons across these different
systems
um in the olap space and i found it very
helpful
to to better understand this world so
that was a great talk and i'd encourage
folks
to check that out
um so so then to continue the
conversation
um about the internals of pinot um
let's talk about the the query language
options because i think that starts to
play off
um some of these architectural decisions
that you were that you were just
previously discussing
yeah so we we made a change in our query
language a little
uh like six months ago so we we had a
very
it's a small subset of sql so we what we
call it as p no query language
uh but uh in order to improve that
option and make sure that it's easy for
people to use pino
we moved to sql and we started using
calcite as our
interface right so because that's kind
of uh well-known standard out there and
we didn't want
we wanted to reduce the learning curve
for people to use pino
having said that i wanted to bring a
little bit about the two paradigms that
are there in the world in terms of
the query execution itself so there is
this world where you say that
uh data and compute should be together
and then there is another world where
you say the computer and data is
separate
right so there is and both these have
grow the pros and cons right and you can
always get very very good latency with
data and compute together
and that's where pino shines and and we
have this
um amazing indexes and then
data locality and all those things
already built in to give you that low
latency
so the query the language the query
language that we are
[Music]
we have is is kind of trying to enhance
that
model which is you should be able to
push down as much
things as possible towards the data
where the data is
instead of pulling the data to you to
where where the computers
and as part of that what the way we are
looking into
the query languages providing new
operators
right for example distinct count is is a
classic operator that we did where
you have to pull in everything because
you cannot do any local computation for
a distinct count
right now you have to pull all the data
back to the broker and then there is a
central place where you are com
doing the distinct uh but what we did is
we allowed uh we added primitives like
partitioning
and a sub special operator when there is
partitioning and data is already
partitioned
we can actually push down the
computation to each node
the distincts are actually computed on
the node and then you just simply sum it
up
right so there are a lot of these
advantages that we get now the query
which would take like
seconds and minutes would now get
completed in milliseconds
right so we are adding lots and lots of
operators which allow us to push down a
lot of these computation
so we are doing funnel analysis inner
queries
um and basket analysis all these things
where we can push down a lot of
computation
uh to the storage and adding operators
to
basically capitalize on that um but
apart from that
the rest of them we will keep it similar
to sql um
and then it's it's very similar to sql
in terms of the query language
love it i love that architecture and so
then what about your storage
um layer like what does that look like
so right now it is uh local this we have
our own
format it's uh i mean most of people
it's very similar to arrow in fact
i i one of the things that we didn't do
very well is kind of
remove the storage of the segment pinot
segment format
in fact even before arrow came in we had
all those technologies in dino
we just didn't decouple it and extract
it as a as a component
if we have the ability to store the
primitives the multi arrays and being
able to access them
in a vectorized form all those things
are already built in um so that's we
have our own pinot segment format
as part of the storage and we capitalize
on being able to
map only a segment of it and a small
chunk of
it and then be able to capitalize on
making sure that we don't pull a lot
into the memory
so a lot of those things are already
built in but it's
it's not made for the network format
like how arrow was
focused on we we focused more on the
disc to the
the processing layer so that's where
the segment storage format comes into
picture okay
got it well um keychain the chat's been
quiet so
far so i'm just a reminder to folks if
you have questions
um for kishore we have the olap expert
here so
um feel free to to drop in the chat
um also i should say that if anybody
sends me a cool
company swag i might just use it on the
next show
nice people at sequoia sent this to me
so
i thought i'd just take a little sip um
but
we're just trying to find around here
keisha
um so here's a question uh
what's the best way for someone with
less experience to learn about all the
historical pressures that led to design
decisions
and tools in the data space so that's a
pretty
general generalized question um
but a good one um t-shirt what what do
you recommend
can you repeat that i didn't get it so
someone is looking for
how to um somebody with less experience
and how would they
get up to speed um with some of the
design
design decisions and the surrounding
pressures
that sort of go into you know how you
decide um which kind of architecture to
build in these certain situations i
guess
that mostly comes with professional
experience right like this is the whole
notion of being able to work at maybe
larger tech companies
that have bigger data sets bigger
scalability challenges
latency requirements and once you get
thrown into these situations where
you have that scale that scale
produces this type of experience so i
guess that's
that's one way um are there other ways
you can think of to
sort of accelerate your career in the
data world definitely i think
uh looking at reference architectures at
various companies
right and you want to pick um
pick an architecture which has minimal
number of components
but being able to solve maximum number
of use cases right and
what that means is that they have
figured out
the interoperability of these systems i
mean obviously you can't have one system
that's pretty much solves all the
problems
uh but you want to figure out the
reference architecture where
the pieces fit well with each other
right it's almost like you're
you're building a tall building with
these your lego boxes
you want to make sure that they have
good uh
match and they're able to interact very
well with each other
um you don't want the impedance match
there yeah
yeah so a reference architecture that
solves with the with the fewest number
of components the largest number of use
cases yeah
and typically the big company would have
already seen most of the use cases um
and then you want to think a little bit
have a forward thinking in terms of
even though you have just one use case
right now
it's it's inevitable that you will have
more use cases down the road
so pick something that you can sustain
for a few years so that
you don't have to keep changing the
systems
yeah i like that um so
on that note as sort of a segue to the
next topic um
you've made some decisions as to how
pinot's going to play
inside the broader data ecosystem um
and some of this probably flows out of
your design decisions
and some of the trade-offs that you made
but some of this is also just
philosophical about
how you want to rely on other people in
the data world
to benefit pino versus you trying to do
everything
yourself can you talk talk to us a
little bit about how you
integrate with other tools and what
tools those are you mentioned presto
earlier so um you might be able to share
more a little bit there
sure i think that yeah as you mentioned
right though
earlier if you kind of go back like 10
15 years back right
oracle was doing everything like there
was these are like monolith systems you
would put data there you would query so
you pretty much get everything etl
everything pretty much would just happen
within within one system
and and with the big data and the real
time and like
just the explosion in the data size you
just cannot have all these things done
very well in one system
and as you see we are like kind of you
know the entire thing is broken up so if
you look at any
tech stack you have these data sources
like the bottom which is like
either your real time or the batch and
then you have your processing or the etl
systems
and then you have the storage um and
then you have the compute
right so you kind of you can break it up
into these four layers
and every layer is actually very complex
and
you have like so many different systems
in every layer available right now
right so if you look at the data sources
you have s3 you have
uh azure you have gcs you have kafka pub
sub
pulsar like you have so many different
things and then you go to the next layer
there are
no fling samsa sparks
bunch of hadoop and other systems so
it's it's very important for us to
make sure that the interfaces on these
layers
are actually very well established and
then you are
you are also keeping it flexible uh in
terms of being able to plug into kafka
or
observe any other pop sub systems um so
that's
that's one of the things that we try to
do because we don't want to solve
all the four layers because it's almost
impossible to get everything
done and then each player as i mentioned
is so complicated
that you want to do the best job in the
layer that you are focusing on
so for me it was really about
providing latent very very good latency
on a single table so that was very very
clear
agenda in our mind which is be the
fastest
pinot to be the fastest single table uh
query engine
right and what that meant was we had to
give up on things like joins and other
complex window functions and things like
that
so but then presto was very very good in
terms of
having this very good connector
ecosystem the connector spi
and uh we capitalize on that so we said
like we are not going to do the joints
and all
these complex systems but we will uh let
the experts
uh in presto community actually solve
that problem
and then but we will focus on building a
very smart connector
right so that's kind of what we did at
uh the folks at uber actually came up
with this
idea which is epino has this amazing
latency
and presto has this amazing flexibility
which provides
entire things so why can't we just
combine these two
and then build a system that provides
the best of both worlds right
and the connector is not like the the
standard
you know presto connector which would
pretty much think the underlying system
is a dumb system and then it would try
to pull everything as a file
um but in this case they were able to
push down a lot of computation
into pino right so the way the connector
itself is smart enough looking at the
query is like
oh this is an aggregation query i can
just push as much as possible
into uh into pino so that's kind of
the way we thought about it and then say
that if there is another
system which is doing an amazing job
let's capitalize on that
instead of trying to build everything in
inside pinot and then
make sure the pinot is best in one thing
which is this is
fastest single table query engine
that's kind of how we how we thought
about it
well it requires that kind of clarity i
mean i
advise a lot of startup founders and
engineers starting companies and
um sometimes uh it's a similar kind of
clarity that you need
um not just in terms of sort of how you
build your technology but just how you
build your product
and what you want to focus on and
us engineers know that when you focus on
one thing there's a trade-off and that
you can't focus on something else and so
sometimes those trade-offs are
are complicated and difficult and seem
like what like decisions that we don't
want to make
but um with this principle of you
you know reducing latency against a
single table
um it's amazing what you've done with
the system and you've come up with very
creative ways
to handle the the the use cases that you
want to support against this
the system and you know maybe pena will
be a reference architecture for
um some computer science program
somewhere i don't know if anyone's
approached you yet but
i think uh i i can imagine that would be
rewarding for you and it would make
sense
in my mind looking forward to that
um so so keisha we're almost out of time
but um
i know that the the pinot community is
growing and
you have 600 plus people in your slack
channel um at the moment
and there's other stuff going on um tell
us about some of the things you're
excited about
in the penal community yeah i think
one of the key things that we found i
mean we were like just 100
early early this year right so we we had
a lot of improvement in the slack
community and a lot of engagement from
from the users and the key things that
we
kind of learned over this was our
documentation was not there right i
think
that was one and two as we
were operating this in world like
linkedin and uber
which were pretty much on-prem systems
right uh
data systems where data centers so we
didn't focus
a lot on the cloud native like how do we
run it on the cloud
so we put together the kubernetes
operators and making sure that it's
super easy to run
on on these cloud environments and it
was not very hard for us because
we already had integration with helix
and helix loves this kind of dynamic
environment where the nodes can just go
up and down and the system just
works so once we put that together we
saw a huge
increase in in the interest in pino and
the number of users asking and the
wonderful questions right i think
a lot of times you you just put
something together and then
they're the ones who come back and then
say hey you can actually do this right
in fact
uh the partition distinct count was
influenced by one of the users now so we
didn't have that but we
quickly found that hey we already have
the primitives to support something like
this
and he was able to get get the query
from like 90 seconds to like few
milliseconds
right so that's that's a huge uh input
so it's
kind of you first help them but then
they help you a lot
later so it's amazing to see that and
that's very very encouraging
for us to actually continue to help more
people
um kind of learn what are the use cases
the basket analysis is another one which
we thought
oh we couldn't do it but then people
people
say that hey you can actually do it it's
it's it's like this and
it helps you learn a lot there so it was
very
useful uh exercise in terms of talking
to users they come up with
new use cases they kind of pushing the
boundaries of of you know
right but at the same time sticking to
the principle like
don't go beyond beyond the single table
thing and then but make sure that you
are able to support more and more use
cases on single table
and about how many contributors do you
have for pino these days
so we have we are getting a lot of
contributions from outside
there are a lot of people who just want
to learn distributed systems
and then we do encourage them in terms
of
taking up small tasks so we have more
than 100 plus
uh like 120 or 30 i don't know the exact
number so there's lots of
contributors and the nice thing that we
have a word
which is one of the key principles that
we also had at linkedin
was always be on master so we don't have
any branches we don't have force it's
the same
whatever you see in the open source is
the same thing that's running on
linkedin uber
so that's like i'm amazing for us to
maintain that quality and at the same
time
how like we have like almost thousand
comments just in this year
um so that's we every every day there is
one or the other comment that is getting
in and then
we have set up all the um testing and
everything to make sure that we can
always be on
on track based development and not
create branches
well um we're we're almost out of time
oh we have one more question uh kishore
is there auto scaling in the pipeline
i'm not sure is that the ingest pipeline
as so there is there is auto scaling in
terms of can be in
in every layer so auto scaling can be in
the injection layer
as well as on the query layer so we
don't have auto scaling
like built-in but we do have external
metrics that can be monitored to scale
it because
the rebalancing is almost in no downtime
uh
api where you can just simply add a new
node
and then call a rebalance api and
everything happens in the background
um so if you really want to build an
auto scaling feature
you should be able to build on top of
the existing primitives
but but that's something that we plan to
add but
not no one has really asked for it right
now um so i think it's it's something
and and once we see users asking for it
it should be a very easy thing to add
got it um it seems like the question
might have been in reference
to compute or storage
um which are two different things um how
do you handle auto scaling there
uh so in in case of pino right now we
the computer and storage are together so
if you're scaling one the other one
scales too
so it's it's not decoupled i mean that's
uh
something down the road but probably
early next year is when we will
try to separate the two for some use
cases especially when when you want like
tiering support where your old data can
have a compute and storage separately
but the fresh one you want the computer
and storage to be get together
got it well um it's been great to chat
with you
kishore i think i think that's that's
just about all the time we have
um but but one last question before i
let you go
what was the most surprising thing that
you've learned so far in building pinot
uh i would say for lesson for myself
would be
that fighting your own opinions
is was the hardest part like you always
start off with an opinion which
which is sometimes strongly held but
then
you want to loosen that up that's that's
one of the things that i
learned that you have some some insights
when you start a project
and you think about okay these are all
the things that and you make the
decision based on all the data points
that you have at that point
but as you are building the world
changes there are lots of other things
that happen
and you want to be willing to let go of
some of the opinions that you had in the
beginning and then adapt as the
technology changes
and it might be either you learn new
things that you were
and you realize that you were wrong
earlier or the world around you changes
and you want to
adapt to that i think those that was one
of the key things where
i had to make some compromises where i
thought
initially i thought it's almost
impossible to build
such a high throughput low latency
system on a columnar store
right that's that's what my in coming
from an old tp world where i was
serving millions of queries on on b3
and then thinking of serving something
like this on a column
store was almost i i myself was like
no this is not going to happen but uh i
learned a lot of things there was
ssd that came into picture which helped
us to achieve some of this right i think
i would say it is impossible on disk to
get this kind of a
throughput and low latency but then ssd
help so
so there are a lot of things that can
happen um so that would be my
that would be one of the things if you
are trying to start out to build a
system
um you'll you'll learn a lot um and
be be flexible be adaptive learn learn
how the world around you is also
changing
well flexibility is not always one of
the qualities that i would
apply to characteristics that i would
apply to us engineers but
that's very well said so thanks for
sharing your experience with us
it's obvious in the way you talk about
these systems that you've seen
so many of them so i really appreciate
you sharing with the community
so uh just in terms of a couple final
closing
notes for the community our next dc
thursday is going to be on october 22nd
it's going to be on cube flow with anime
singh from ibm
and then mark your calendars for
november 5th
we're going to be talking with dmitry
petrov who's the founder of dvc
which should be a great talk so if you
have a minute or two
please drop your feedback in the form
if you don't mind the formats in the the
youtube chat
helps us calibrate on what topics you're
interested in
and things that we can do to always be
improving around here
so that'd be really appreciated and
remember that all the dc
thursday episodes from the past if you
missed any they're in our youtube
playlist
on our youtube channel so you can feel
free to subscribe there
and yeah thanks everyone i'm looking
forward to seeing you all in a couple
weeks